sure he's actually kind of down to earth
guy and
uh yeah yeah he will just uh
so that's why i also don't think he's so
excited to play magnus sir
yeah that's why no i think it's a very
good point yeah so that's why i
prefer to play izzy panko
okay and that's a berlin from ezypenko
wow magnus moving on
d4 edie
knows seems to know what he's doing or
what
yeah knight a5 queen a4
taking the bishop early a6 you are
forcing bishop take c6 otherwise
heroes here knight a5 queen a4
and now it's uh magnus to think of
course it looks very ski for
for black but who knows
yeah it looks very odd to me but yeah
will you play a queen e1
is that the move i don't know
it's very possible bishop d2 was one why
not
i mean knight for knight c3 for instance
looks dangerous to me
take stakes okay one coming
queen f3 coming
no doubt about that
yeah kind of unpleasant huh yeah in
this game not so funny indeed
f3 bishop e6 i probably would go here
c4 or whatever yeah something like that
yeah still looks like you're not out
with black but okay
played bishop c3 magnus carlsen which
came as a surprise
so it seems okay still played reasonably
fast
this is pankoya playing with no fear
okay it's playing his pipe
so it's too early to judge
of course you don't play with any fear
when you check the line
with i don't know a super strong
computer and at home
and you're just repeating on the board
of and generally you're not
not very feared here but still i mean
this position
is um kind of playable for whiter
yeah that's for sure let me just sit in
92 put a knight on c4 and
probably mathematics wouldn't doesn't
mind to play these kind of positions
it's not easy also for for for
for black to do anything yeah
that's true because i mean you run into
some prep but
okay it's not like you have to find only
moves
no it's not the end of the world yeah
that's true i think d5 should be played
here now
because if you don't go d5 then castle
will just go like dc4
and after d5 knight e5 is coming so
that's
so d5 now maybe but then edie knight d5
ah bishop g7 knight e3 will come you
know
actually that was the reason why
actually was bounding
if you had to go knight to a3 that's
okay it looks it looks strange but yeah
yeah maybe it's clever actually
92 d5 played by the young
man from russia
yes interesting i was thinking maybe
just to play queenie too
okay one played yeah yeah let's clear
your sideline huh
what did ezipenko
[Music]
so yes five plus three increment not
botched branchline
if we move you get c seconds extra
so flagging is not really involved while
in armageddon
it's a different story
castle d1 played immediately
a nice uh mesh to coordinate his
pieces quite in quite a nice way i think
yes no it's a typical position actually
this
suits magnus very well
on d8
not going down on time that's probably
one of the key to success for azipenko
my dc4 played anyway i want 95 and 96
on the other one to c6
okay that's so clear actually that's
very clear what you want here
what you have to remove the queen i
guess queenie it's queen
queen b5 ready it's not yeah there's a4
and you have to go to e80 major thing
so knight t5 maybe
yeah then maybe i'll take home e4 yeah
probably you have to
i take here i probably take the
bishop but yeah i like my
i mean that might come i'm sorry might
come
queen g3 it feels very easy to play for
white
yeah i agree
it's not true you will make it in by
writing unfortunately
it's a grandparent so i have a
grandparent yeah even yeah yeah because
he lost a lot of ratings so
who knows
so that would just only leave him the
chance to qualify in
this open october in the isle of man but
it's going to be very tough
okay he played queen eight he took on d5
didn't want to
to go 95
and wait is slightly better simply some
pressure here knight b7 always queen g3
coming
very hard to play for black and we see
240 only for easy penco
yes maybe but the computer shows it's
maybe not that bad for black but
i you really have to do something
uh concrete i guess like before knight
b6 or whatever
yeah but here it's always uh
but maybe bishop f6 yeah yeah you can go
queen g3 instead yeah queen g3 is nice
f6 and now i take here
okay uh what was play he's still
thinking of course it's very very
difficult to play
he's he's a great player and uh
i mean he will become a great player he
can go he feels a critical moment
very very impressive anyway to be here
already
against the world champion is a great
achievement
yeah i don't see an easy easy solution
here for black
can i go as simple knight before maybe i
have to do something like that
maybe 120
for easy penco cringes f6
uh takes takes yeah
this has to be calculated for instance
and you can be just uh completely lost
here
it's not impossible
yeah yeah one minute for izzy panko he
shouldn't
if you end up with 30 seconds against
magnus it's
over not over but very difficult king
shade played off
that's more
you better what you want to do it
defends if we have rook g8 i cannot
imagine that
probably wants to keep the knight on d5
here yeah
yeah it's not so easy for white to
improve
quincy played f6 will be probably played
on g8 yes way
yeah i'm with you here i cannot imagine
f6 okay one now
yeah of course so difficult for izzy
penko
knight c6 now will come over here yeah
but okay at least this bishop on b2 is
blocked but c5
might might become weaker yeah exactly
i can go see if i immediately you cannot
go knight before
because i take and take can i go bishop
d6 here
ah
my
now maybe bishop e3 is even stronger
yeah
yeah i took first yeah i was
that was weird maybe queen f2 no
bishop
okay trying to find some cutter play
that's what you have to do
take knight f4 and okay let's go queen
g6 i know
of course that kind of stuff normally it
doesn't work in its magnets
yeah it's just a pawn down
it's just a calm down and
if two weak pawns on the on the queen
side
situation is looking very grim
situation looks very crim grim for mr
marco
yes now pressing rook takes d5
and take on e7 then
so what's what did the play
we don't see i haven't updated
i i'm missing some move here
d7 or q4 i think but not sure
ah okay mm-hmm yeah rg7 okay four was
played
bishop f5 now he's taking
queen takes and
probably queen f2 yeah keep it solid
okay but some now some chances for
survival
clearly for sure contour play knight c3
yeah okay still it's uh it's a pawner
it's a pawn but yeah eight seconds
against fifteen it's blitz
it's blitz
it's definitely very difficult
yes it's no it's just i still now it's
hard to win yeah
yeah opposite bishop what is he doing
can we have um
he's not happy magnus carlsen he played
with little time on the clock
yeah i wanted this view because
for the world champion but so difficult
to convert
opposite score bishop but maybe this
pawn is going to be weaker this h4 pawn
hour
yeah but you have to do something it's
blitz after all
oh and it seems to be uh
playing very fast and very well izipenko
takes bishop takes
yeah right
now i think it's salidoria you go to b1
yeah you go to b1 it's going to be one
queen c2 is
india
big threat
if a frequency two
a7 wow yeah i want to play queen c5 with
queen e7 the same
same same thing bishop d3 once
go to g4 i could have well going to g4
was better but you want to d2
protected
f2 followed by qh4 was over i think
but this is the bishop is now dominated
25 going for that
is that winning that's winning
this is a weird decision because it's uh
the poem of g2
panic i mean come on yes 10 seconds so
yeah so what what's it
what's the what oh it's an excuse it's
funny
b4 yes if bishop to b5
b5 it's over to spawn f6 g5 h4 look at
that this is too weak
you can even play yeah you just take
back here yeah it's
it's uh it's easy now
but d7 now
will be played of course d7 now b6 first
d7 yeah king takes
bishop f6 bishop g5 bishop h4 as the
next move design will come
wow congratulations magnus carson wins
the first blitz it's not over
it's not over